relationship advice yeah i like this
full set of lips look at that nice chain
what's up brendan vaughn what's up theo
shop how's it hanging nick and chin
and how's it going to whatever guest you
guys got in the studio this week because
you guys fired captain chappelle
from honolulu hawaii and i need some
relationship advice from you guys
my girlfriend's been wanting to wax my
[ __ ]
and i just don't know how to feel about
it we don't look hair hand
it'll probably make her a little happier
you know every man give me a little
extra
points really on the other hand every
man really is not looking down there you
know i don't know
check how it looks every day i don't
care how hairy it gets that thing can
grow wild for all i care
but what do you guys think when your
girlfriend wax around hang it doggy
do it here's the thing though i had my i
my girl wanted to do it to me too and i
was like sure why not
and i said but let's try it just on my
inner thigh see how bad it hurts
dude hurts right girls go through it all
the time
dude not funny i want you are not
touching my [ __ ]
yeah to us to shave their [ __ ]
i mean i guess i would let her do it i
mean it's bonding
you know what i mean shaving is
different from waxing your [ __ ]
though he said waxing
so waxing is like piping hot wax on your
ass it doesn't even have to be piping
hot they have cool waxes now
the only problem is when you pull it
you're pulling even the hair follicle it
hurts but here's the thing with me
is i have a skin tag on my [ __ ] so
and i've been trying to get it off so i
feel like that would work
i would use the guys of hey can you wax
my [ __ ] this would be fun buying
anything but really i want to get the
wart off my ass
oh that might do it then yes you might
have to say yes you
no i think it's a skin tag the doctor
says it's a skin tag
it [ __ ] hurts but it's also not that
bonding because you either got you know
if your girl's gonna do it you gotta
decide baby style where you're holding
your ankles
oh you're all legs she's grabbing the
balls and like going like this where
it's super
weird uncomfortable or yeah yeah on all
fours like a you know
and spread this how would you do it i'd
probably go baby stop put that
nuts in her face
i would i think i would go i would go
all fours because i think if i went baby
style
one thousand percent i'd fart and then
if i farted
because every time i do that like even
if i haven't eaten in three days
like if i do as soon as i go into that
position i just fart
just immediately just almost like a
crunch dude and it's like yeah
i'll queef like it'll just yeah
so i would go on all fours but i think
this kid should one thousand percent let
his girl do it
i think he shouldn't report back but
also asian
like you're not that hairy if you want
your girl to eat your ass that's it
the pain is so it's so painful
especially for a man
because you have more hair there there's
more to rip off right it's going to hurt
like a [ __ ] if you don't want to
do it already
do you like your acid i've never gotten
my acid and i've never had any sex
he's just embarrassed about the skin tag
you didn't want people to see it that's
a good point
i think i've had the skincare cd eats
ass i swear to god i don't eat s
not that i'm against it i just because i
get a lot of sore throats not since the
panty waiting
no you wear masks and wash our hands but
i would always get sore throats like if
i
made out with like a couple of girls or
if i like ever like went down
on a girl i would get a sore throat
immediately so i was taking the ass i
mean i would get full cancer
you get pink eye yeah that's kind of a
rumor too don't you get pink eye yeah
what you're saying you don't no no right
but you do the only way to get pink eyes
fecal particles in the eye right
i don't think so didn't kirk douglas get
uh
throat cancer but that's from hpv
because you eat out girls with hpv
or suck penis with hpv i don't know what
kurt russell's into uh no not kurt
russell douglas
douglas yeah kurt let's just start the
room at kurt russell
yeah i but i think i think um
yeah i've never done it dude i've never
i've never even tried anal sex that's
that's so disappointing would you uh let
your girl wax your [ __ ] oh yeah
go for it oh wow nice good for you who
cares do you think you have a hairy
[ __ ]
i probably do you know like he's a bear
dog you know that's bad
there's nothing i
i'll tell you he's been doing work
overtime if they wax their [ __ ]
oh my god dude you got a duck tail down
there it's like the elastic jungle from
guts
cords all over i think cat hit it on the
head though like this is just a gateway
request she's doing it to get it clean
and then the next is can i she wants to
eat your ass like that's what you get in
there girls
i couldn't even nothing wrong with that
[Applause]
it feels good huh try it out with your
girl man
yeah put your kids no you can't put your
kid put your kid to bed early take a
shower
get on all fours and just let her eat
the ass
it's interesting i've never even thought
about it dude it's a nightmare
there's not enough wet wipes to clean my
ass yeah
i know maybe you need that bidet i do
that's what i do
would you be down for a cat if stevie
was like i really like my ass you know
uh if stevie asked i asked i'd be open
to it i've had
other guys have dated in the past asked
for it and i always said no
because i just yeah i don't trust their
them or their hygiene
right i don't respectfully stevie has
ocd though so you know he's clean
i know he's clean but there's something
about like maybe it's just me i always
felt like white people
never really cleaned their ass properly
i agree with that
yes i don't that's racist yeah yeah i
agree that is racist that's right stevie
is the cleanest man i've ever he has ocd
yes absolutely he might be thick hairy
down there because he has that thick
he doesn't walk anywhere near his butt
but here's that prison yeah
how long did he do seven years uh seven
or eight years fed eight years in
federal prison that's a yeah that's
significant that's a life-changing
amount of time
think about how long
what did he do what was the crime i
think drug trafficking
money laundering conspiracy uh selling
drugs and they gave eight heroes like
that yeah because he was young he was
like 20 21
and they gave him eight years yeah he
took a deal
wow so we could have gotten way more
yeah he could have gotten more have you
ever met steven
blue no was he a comedian yeah yeah
no i never met him huge cop really he
also used to be
he used to do porn where can i see his
work uh i'll have him send me a pic
pornhub probably online what's his uh
what's his name
you know uh nicole anderson uh i know
jennifer aniston
nope nope who's nicole aniston porn
biggest
dude foreign dumbbells you don't know do
your acid
or jerk off to women's tennis
[Laughter]
okay so you've never seen her that was
this girl before cat
mm-hmm okay upgrade oh thanks
i think nicole is beautiful though super
dynamic stunning so
i've seen it in person and do they still
now if nicole aniston
and stevie blois were to do a porn scene
together you're okay with that uh
not anymore no uh initially he and i
first started dating
i was i didn't really want to spend
extra time with him because of that i
was like
oh like we'll hang out hook up whatever
but i don't want anything more to do
with you then he quit
porn because he knew i wouldn't want
anything to do with him because of that
he quit porn because that and then also
i can't have you on the road with me
i can't have porn star yeah i love you
but
yeah i can't be associated with that
yeah yeah i get it we got a business to
run here
it's interesting though because porn
stars because he's just going to work
like that's what it would be he just
goes to work and yeah
he'll be okay just puts his boots on and
everything he's watching yeah it's not
his fault he's gifted with that
thick white i'd like to see his [ __ ] can
we pull his [ __ ] up yeah we pull up
that he hides from there we can't see uh
hey she knows where to get it
yeah she's a big one can we just get
stevie blue eyes penis she wants to see
it
um let me ask him i'd like to see it oh
yeah
you can send him that you could tell
them say hey you sent us a pic
right now i'm just on the toilet
fingering my [ __ ]
you've seen his hammer too yeah like he
pulls it out it's like this cake
iguana tail dog really just [ __ ]
that's hot
[Music]